y
[Música]
desde hace tiempo no compramos ropa ropa
vieja harapos o vestimenta adquirimos el
derecho de hacer parte de un universo
devolvernos los personajes de un gran
relato imaginado por las marcas de moda
y dicho guión se está reescribiendo
actualmente los desfiles ya no tienen
lugar por aquello de la pandemia pero
las fashion weeks continúan en parís
hubo una el pasado mes de marzo en la
página de la federación de la costura y
la moda se puede observar que durante
nueve días las 94 marcas inscritas se
tienen cada una un horario tal como
antes pero hoy en día proponen películas
como la del new york' y no tom brown el
que pone en escena al in sifón la
campeona olímpica estadounidense de
esquí que nos introduce en un
maravilloso cuento de navidad' no
olvidemos que son colecciones de
invierno este sistema de la fashion week
digital es limpio calmado sereno se lee
el programa es mágico quien presentó de
primero sorpresa por primera vez no es
una marca sino una escuela parisina el y
fm el instituto francés de la moda cuyo
objetivo es volverse uno de los cinco
mejores campus de moda del mundo
la película presenta a granel los
trabajos de los 70 estudiantes del
programa de máster pero cuando se
observa en detalle se empiezan a
percibir los talentos de mañana ejemplos
mudasir mohamed para celebrar a su
familia originaria del sur de india
integra en sus investigaciones recuerdos
del final del colonialismo
es una túnica que convertí y que cuenta
la misma historia que una túnica
ordinaria pero usa una tela que
generalmente se usa para fabricar los
aros
y cree una estructura en el interior
para generar peso para que caiga como un
traje
esto es una camiseta ordinaria
pero la corte en dos es muy agradable
se siente pasar el aire alrededor de sí
mismo
pero también se puede hacer una
mascarilla con ellos
es habitual entre los obreros cuando no
cuentan con mascarillas de protección
soucek ine es surcoreana apasionada de
las estructuras eligió estudiar las
carteras
en este tipo de cartera cuando la abre
se amplía toda su forma
ésta se puede volver un blando pero
cuando la sierra se vuelve totalmente
diferente
un poco de fantasía
no hay
las palabras claves de mi proyecto son
extensión y transformación
mayol harley estudia el mundo de las
imágenes reflexionan sobre los asuntos
relacionados con la masculinidad la
feminidad el género construye
representaciones gráficas que interpela
nats
estamos en una época en la que debemos
tener esta idea de transparencia
lo que aún no ocurre pero para mí
estamos empezando a hablar en la
realidad de las cosas
la gente está cansada de las cosas
falsas
las imágenes retocadas como aquellas
publicidades sofisticadas en las que las
modelos se ven muy lindas
necesitamos diversidad personas que
existan creo en ello
abandonemos los nacientes talentos para
reunirnos en sudáfrica con un joven
diseñador confirmado de fama google él
también lucha por la diversidad en 2019
a sus 29 años es el diseñador más joven
en llevarse el prestigioso y lucrativo
premio lv n aquí la película que
presenta hoy se refiere a la explotación
de los años 70 esa corriente cultural y
social con un poder liberador
porque históricamente los negros siempre
han sido descritos de una u otra manera
como víctimas
con esta película queríamos que todos
los personajes sean héroes pueden ser
descritos como héroes y todas las
mujeres en esta película cuentan con un
sentido agudo de la independencia de
autonomía
y reivindicará una victimización negra
tal como en el pasado
los tiempos cambian a medida que cada
vez más personas negras ocupan lugares
de primera línea
como sorpresa existe
platicó
la película una historia de amor entre
dos mujeres pretende ser el reflejo de
los interrogantes de la sociedad
africana actual
la colección recuerda la idea de la
espiritualidad africana era un concepto
lejano para mí pero cada vez más amigos
gente alrededor de mí comienzan a
abandonar el cristianismo y todas esas
cosas a las que tuvimos que suscribir
para volvernos totalmente africanos
entrar a la espiritualidad africana hace
parte de ellos y mis amigas son jóvenes
mujeres modernas estudiantes de derecho
a algunas diseñadoras
[Música]
perfiles modernos que se mezclan con un
ángulo indígena cuando se vuelven
sanadoras tradicionales la modernidad y
el indigenismo con frecuencia han sido
considerados como opuestos con esta
colección quería ver como los dos podían
fusionarse realmente una propuesta
visual jóvenes promesas aún en los
escritorios de la escuela o diseñador
confirmado misma lucha usar la moda para
impactar el curso del mundo
[Música]